foreign
okay we did the largest study of
millionaires ever done in North America
my friend Tom Stanley who passed away a
few years ago his daughter Sarah has
continued his work wrote a book in
1992 called The Millionaire Next Door
he studied 750 millionaires he was a
marketing professor at Georgia State
University and he sold eight bazillion
of those books and became the
millionaire next door but uh that book
was extremely popular but the critics uh
the the leftists all said oh well who'd
never take statistics classes 750 is not
a large enough sample size to draw the
conclusions of where millionaires really
come from however it is statistically
significant and it is actually
excellent research but these are people
that don't know me so when we got ready
to do this 30 years later
we said all right 30 years later let's
relook the idea where do millionaires
come from let's survey millionaires I
said 750 is statistically significant
but we know the leftists aren't going to
like it the Communists aren't going to
like it when we say that America is not
so broken you can't win so we better
have more than enough let's go let's
just go 10 times statistically
significant let's study 7 500
millionaires well we got carried away
and we ended up surveying and studying
10 167 of them
and to we can't find anybody that
studied anywhere near that larger sample
size or the data that it says tightly
roped in our research technique and
methodology was airtight to the point
that if you don't agree with the
conclusions of this study you are what's
known as wrong
okay that's how that type this data is
so here's an interesting one
98 of millionaires that's all of them
when asked the question
can you become a millionaire today in
America said yes
well of course they did
they're millionaires
I mean ask a guy who rides a bike
do you believe people in America can
ride a bike today 98 will say yeah yeah
I can run you know I rode a bike the
other guy rode a bike you're gonna ride
a bike I mean because you've done it
people who haven't done it are the ones
that doubt you know that's the thing 69
percent of Americans when we study the
general public asked the same question
only 69 believed it was still possible
so it turns out belief
causes action if you don't believe
saving money will make you rich then why
would you save money
so first you have to believe that it
works and then you take action on that
belief so belief is part of the equation
the other thing of course is this famous
thing of well all money's inherited
79 of millionaires inherited precisely
zero so far today we've talked to four
they've inherited precisely zero another
five percent of the millionaires we talk
to did get an inheritance but it was
mathematically so small that it would
not cause you to become a millionaire
like Grandma left them five thousand
bucks
that kind of stuff okay another five
percent received a substantial
inheritance after they were already
millionaires so it obviously didn't
cause them to become a millionaire like
you might got 250 000 bucks but you
already had a net worth of 2.5 so let me
help you with a 79-0 five small and five
after that's 89. that's nine out of ten
of America's millionaires did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
when someone tells you that they are at
a minimum wrong at a maximum lying
[Music]
you don't have to inherit it you have to
do the stuff to get there though